hold on to your love of nantes TV
because we're about to time travel once
upon a time in the age of busy patterns
dial-up modems and the real running man
[Music]
what is truly American is why culture to
a large degree on the television and
that's how so many people see the 1990s
but it's not really true or is this down
to just clouding our recollection so
everybody kind of looks on on the Golden
Age in terms of when they were young
hey fam I'm a Mayan this is a j+ and
this Sunday we're explain why so many
think the 90s was the Golden Age of
black sitcom why there aren't more black
sitcoms on TV today and if there's any
chance they'll come back because I might
want to cameo
[Music]
there was a time when the sitcom was
dead two television executives like rest
in peace dead they were moved by TV
shows like mash Dallas dynasty and
magnum p.i dramas dominated the ratings
in the early eighties and then something
unexpected happened once that showed how
popular sitcoms could be they came back
with a vengeance
that's what we're Network executive and
TV historian Tim Brooks
he says the birth of what some see as a
black sitcom boom actually begins in the
1980s with The Cosby Show it had some of
the highest ratings ever recorded for
sitcom
it finished third in the ratings in its
first year and first the next four
seasons and if you get it together and
drop these macho attitudes you and never
gonna have anybody bringing you anything
anywhere any place any time ever had a
period from about 84 until the early 90s
who are black sitcoms were very
prevalent and the big hits on network
television and what happened in the 90s
was that the black sitcoms had all
fallen in the wake of The Cosby Show I'm
an expert when it comes to
family matters The Fresh Prince of
bel-air and a different world are just a
few of the hit shows networks turned out
after the success of The Cosby Show so
if you are one of those people who did
the Urkel
you can sort of blame Bill Cosby when
NBC debuted The Cosby Show in 1984 it
basically rescued the peacock from a
dismal third place position then in 1986
a new network join the media landscape
dominated by NBC ABC and CBS
this was the birth defect starting on a
fox finally decided to take a cue from
the success of black sitcoms on the big
three by creating programming geared
toward a young african-american and
Latino market in 1991 it already had the
black sketch show in living color and it
out of the sitcom Rock the next few
years brought even more blacks it comes
to the network by the mid-90s Fox was
hearing a bunch of black sitcoms that is
until it wasn't
in 1994 according to the the success of
Fox built it up and then the network
began seeking young white male
viewership the lady laughs why would
they well a strange thing was happening
in the 90s audience viewing habits were
changing black and white audiences had
had similar viewing habits in the 1980s
and then of the 90s we see a distinct
split the top TV shows and white
households weren't the same as the
most-watched in black homes for example
Santa was the top-rated show in white
homes in 1997 but only ranked 50th in
black households and a sitcom called
between brothers was number one in black
homes but a hundred and twelfth among
whites and the difference between the
viewer ships was made clearer as other
networks also made room for different
programming The Cosby Show ended in 1992
it's been off a different world which
eventually surpassed it in the ratings
after three years was canceled in 93
that same year NBC launched a new
campaign
must-see TV becomes NBC's Starcross
Thursday and then they kind of faded in
this wave of must-see TV
Thursday night NBC young white single
and the city of kind of things like
friends it kind of sounds like you're
saying gentrification puts black sitcoms
off of television yeah in a sense that's
true and just like with neighborhood
gentrification this type of programming
was pushed to a new area enter the WB
and UPN years before they merged to
become the CW the network Sheeta spots
the same blueprint to gain a foothold
and become the fifth and sixth networks
they even had executives from Fox and
like Fox they to ended up reshaping the
audience after gaining success and as we
came to the end of the road in the 90s
and bounced into the OTT aka the 2000s
watch sitcoms face even more streamed
because the genre was going out of style
we began binging on reality TV if all
sitcoms were in the cold and black
sitcoms of course is a subset of that
without any Cosby Show to spark a way to
and is it possible black sitcoms were
frozen because the sitcom Jonah was no
longer a good vehicle to tell black
stories writer Kyle Hiller says we need
to be very careful about planning over
the 90s black sitcom era just keep the
narrative themselves weren't really
sagging as deeply renewed and I think
that might have something to do as I
said things could fall off into mm and
the way that's to cons are today in
general there are much more dramatic and
they're much more from the confessional
15 days of fast killer says 90s sitcoms
didn't do a good job of digging into the
black American experience and often
relied on
tropes stereotypes and slapstick humor
without delving into why it made fun of
certain things but there's at least one
90s episode he says buck to the formula
and became a memorable moment when
wolves Nick had to handle his father
walking out on him go ahead and get your
tissues ready I learned how to drive I
learn how to shave I learn how to fight
without him I had 14 great birthdays
without him he never even sent me a damn
car I remember that being one of the
first times that I watched television
and struck a chord with me in a way that
I could I had seen anything like
themselves
you don't want me miss that scene may be
a precursor to something that's become a
staple in our media diet the ability to
merge humor and drama in one TV show and
brooke says that's another thing that
helped end the reign of black sitcoms
Desperate Housewives shows like that
we're almost like 1 hours it comes so
that filled the need that viewers had
for comedy and that kind of left the
traditional sitcom out Nicole this
decade brought shows that use the same
mixture of comedy and drama but with
more inclusive casting think orange is
the new black or Atlanta stuff guys I'm
Zen yeah I don't know you and there's
one other thing that's had a major
impact on the number of black sitcoms on
network TV and you're looking at it
right now
the Internet
digital networks like Netflix are
distributing and producing funny shows
with black faces and sometimes they even
have the old 90s favorites available to
streams so yes ABC currently is airing
the hit show blackish before you know
we're gonna be a country full of
youtubing selfie takers living in houses
foolish because nobody knows how to fix
a damn toy but it's one of only a few
black sitcoms slated on the fall 2017
network television schedule and guess
when one of them airs Tuesday nights
after blackish and that's very
interesting because 79 percent of the
audience that watches blackish isn't
black according to Nielsen the audience
for black shows is expansive according
to Brooks and Nielsen's ratings agree
storylines with a strong black character
or identity are crossing cultural
boundaries to grab diverse audiences and
start conversations according to Nielsen
but with Netflix showing a slew of black
stand-up specials while creating
original shows like dear white people
viewers can get their fix online so with
our changing entertainment palette all
this competition and how much the sitcom
has evolved will we ever see a black
sitcom boom like we did in the 1990s
it's so much closer than you think in a
sense we are one hit away I think from a
revival there's nothing inherent in the
black sitcom genre that keeps it off of
television today it's just an example of
doing it right now this is a story all
about how I did this video just for you
and I want to take a minute just to sit
right here to see you like share
subscribe and comment right there